So, Briana Joy Gray, Jill Stein voter, invites me to on her podcast
Bad Faith. My friends tell me, "Don't do it. Bad Faith is known
for being bad faith." I say, "I'll do it anyway." It's like both
[__] up and hilarious that she named her podcast
Bad Faith. Like, [__] up in that she pretty obviously
knows what she is and what she's doing. If you even come close
to [__] up, I'm going to make it look that way like
super hard. Like, I'm going to lean as hard as I possibly can.
It's
>> Why are people talking about ContraPoints again? ContraPoints
are is being talked about because of
her interview with Briana Joy Gray.
Where apparently she gets dunked on by Briana >> that I'm
missing here? Apparently, Bri Brief destroys her. I have like
a thread on this. I'll at least look at the most popular clip.
Where ContraPoints was asked Mad about
She was like very upset about the way this went. This is This
is the big dunking clip, okay? >> point, Ally. Like, at
some point. I mean, is there anything that Democrats would do
that you would say
If If If If Donald Trump, if the 2016 version of Donald Trump
were running against the 2024 Donald
uh on the Democratic ticket
would you say that we should vote for 2016 Donald Donald Trump
because his first term was better than a second
Uh okay. I mean, so I joke about like how I would vote for Satan
to stop Donald Trump. Holy
She really show up this barred out for this interview?
That's crazy.
Uh I totally talk about Donald Trump as a bad meme.
She's like actually about to pass out. Holy [__]
Holy [__]
No wonder she did badly. >> 2016 version of Donald Trump
were running against the 2024 Donald
uh on the Democratic ticket
would you say that we should vote for 2016 Donald Donald Trump
because his first term was better than a second
Uh okay. I mean, so I joke about like how I would vote for Satan
to stop Donald Trump. I There probably is a
I've yet not found it yet of of like what like moral depths to
which I would No, this is way different. This is way way way
different. This is way different than her their her Doom Scroll
pod with with that guy in the like stark white room. This is
way different than how she sounded on the Doom Scroll pod or
whatever, right? I think I think this is
I have a hard time making fun of it. I'll just be real, okay?
It's actually a little difficult for me to make fun of. >> Donald
Trump. So, what does that mean? >> Yeah. And what So, play
that out for me. What do the Everyone always always asking me
to play out my plan. Play Play out the consequences
of vote blue no matter who cuz you keep you and others, I don't
mean to put it all on you, but ask me what the timeline the timeline
the timeline is. I got to this place because I started asking
more centrist oriented people what the timeline is for Medicare
for all. How long are we supposed to deal with the fact that
68,000 people die every year from a lack of health insurance?
What's the timeline on that? And I had people come to me who
were Medicare for all activists in the state of California, who
were Bernie's Medicare for all alls are. And their plans were
minimum 20-year time horizons saying that well, the argument
that was made to me with Gavin Newsom was going to get Medicare
for all in the state of California, that he was going to become
president, and that he was then going to bring Medicare for all
to the entire country. Gavin Newsom doesn't even support Medicare
for all anymore,
>> And the state of California with its overwhelmingly
Democratic legislature
intentionally scuttled their CalCare program now multiple times,
including just recently.
So, at a certain point, I mean, let me let me maybe ask you this
way, Natalie.
I think there there is a problem with doing it in the states,
right? I actually don't know how you do a Medicare for all in
the states if it's not all or nothing. I actually don't know.
I feel like trying to do it as one
can that even possibly work?
I feel like there's almost no way to force that to work as a
state.
Every other public option, but that's not that's not even like
No, you
to get meaningful reform, I do I actually feel like there isn't
a step-wise way to do it. Cuz public
public option-wise, you could start paying less and you could
get but people on it, but unless you mandate it to
how do you get prices down?
You could maybe set a price ceiling by doing a public option.
You could like start to set price ceilings.
How much do you think that donor influence and corporate interests
are determining the policies of the
It was I'll be honest as well. I actually don't even know how
you do it of is a all for all or is an all or nothing thing either.
I I'd actually just seems for the states with how you guys do
pricing and [__] Like it's do economies just crash?
Like localized economies within the health care industry is everything
just
How do you reset all of the pricing
Well, they they certainly have some effect. I think I maybe don't
think they have quite the level of effect that you do because
yes, they have some effect but they also like at the end of the
day do still need to get elected, right? So that I don't think
there's an infinite like capacity for corporate influence. Like
there's a limit to how far you can push it where people will
stop
That limit gets further and further from reality. Like that limit
gets not even That limit gets higher and higher the more like
social media becomes a thing. The more Like I feel like I've
seen the the limits of corporate influence are essentially nothing
now.
>> So long as you could do the whole like bread and circuses,
shifting the narrative, moving everything along, nothing to see
here. So long as you could keep having things explode, different
fires in different places and zoom in on them and make them try
and and make them like big, it feels like corporate influence
has just gone through the ceiling.
Like you straight up had Elon Musk in the government.
I don't know. Well, this is this is kind of my point, [laughter]
that we saw that limit with Gaza and they didn't care,
>> have tried over the years to like I mean Obama came
fairly like like with Affordable Care Act they came fairly close
to getting not Medicare for all but a single payer option. >> Nearly
close and being shot down by Joe Lieberman. Okay, but like why
is it Natalie? We know how slim the Republicans margins are right
now, right? Yeah. And yet they managed to do everything in the
world. Why is it that Barack Obama had a super majority? Had
a super majority. When we say it was scuttled by Joe Lieberman,
we're saying that he was the 60th vote in a super
Yeah. And why is it that it seems to be the case that Democrats
are always one or two votes shy from doing the thing
you know, 75% of the country wants them to do, but Republicans
always manage to push through the thing that only 20% of the
country wants them to do. Well, do you think that
I mean do you really think that like Nancy Pelosi for example
like didn't want a single payer? Like I think that she did. Like
I think
What what did Briahna Joy Gray do for
In defense of Limit Miss Tests with ContraPoints. I joke about
how I would vote for sitting to stop Donald Trump. There probably
is a line I've not found and what moral depths to which I would
stoop to stop Donald Trump, it's pretty
We debate the alleged pragmatism of liberalism, political violence,
and manosphere discourse on the latest Bad Faith. Watch wherever
you get your
Oh, ContraPoints crashed out about this other clip? Oh, there's
a different clip that she crashed out about? Okay. Clip is edited
misleadingly when said by Democratic Party standards about protest
protest voters being far left before Gray mentioned genocide.
When clarified she didn't mean opposing genocide as far >> that
the solution to this is to like to for for if the Democrats pivot
to the far left that there's this like
>> left space. Well, by Democratic Party standards. By
Democratic By Democratic Party standards. Well, isn't that quite
the admission? Well, I'm not saying >> quite the admission
that we have a far I'll be I'll just be real. It's like both
[__] up and hilarious that she named her podcast
Bad Faith. Like [__] up in that she pretty obviously
knows what she is and what she's doing.
But also hilarious that she's willing to just be like, "Yeah.
If you even come close to [__] up, I'm going to make
it look that way like super hard. Like I'm going to lean as hard
as I possibly can." It's
>> Yeah. Like it's pretty obvious. I I can see exactly
how this is going and it's like, "Dude, do you think I I hate
this [__] but maybe some people like it." >> Democratic
Party, if something like ending a genocide is considered to be
far left. Well, I don't think necessarily that particular issue,
but you say I mean you say so Medicare for all, raising the minimum
wage.
I I don't know. To be clear, I don't necessarily think any of
that is far left, right? But like It's populist. It's centrist
politics. >> Yeah, but your position seems to be that
there's this sort of like available untapped voter base that
will manifest if the Democrats
you know, run on these issues. But why doesn't that voter base
manifest in the primaries? I guess is my question. Well, we you
you refuse to acknowledge the riggedness of the primaries. Yeah.
You you refuse to So, I don't know what to tell you. that the
primaries are rigged, but I just feel that you I feel that our
I feel feel like I'm understanding how Hutch got radicalized.
I do I do feel like uh quite a bit I'm understanding how Hutch
could be radicalized by listening to this.
I All the things where I I feel like like in a in a microsecond,
like three of the things I told I've said when I'm watching Hutch,
and like, "Nobody says I feel like Briana Joy Gray is like doing
all of these things. Nobody just argues all the primaries are
rigged, man. Come on. It's like there's no organization behind
it. There's a whole mechanism. There's a whole thing that's there.
And if that's what you mean by rigged, it's not like rigged as
in it was just, you know, you're cut off from doing it. You just
don't have the infrastructure. You build the infrastructure,
eventually they have to start integrating you in. That's why
what Hassan's doing is good, what a lot of these lefties are
doing is good. They're organizing, they're they're getting together,
they're actually fundraising, and they're building their own
organizations that can go and run primaries, run candidates,
and support them.
Like and you will eventually get fully integrated into the Democratic
Party by doing this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I realize she's real. I'm just saying that
like when I say nobody intelligent does this, I do mean
I I do mean like nobody intelligent does this. Like I do think
this is like the worst kind of politics you can engage in. People
who rate the primaries position, they they were openly admitting
it at this point, Natalie. >> the argument that the primaries
are rigged isn't like I feel like the evidence does not rise
to the level where I I feel like rigged is an appropriate description
for what >> Well, what how how would you like
Rigged as in they openly say they put their finger on the scale
for their own candi- their own chosen candidate. Yeah.
Still very winnable.
Like like progressive candidates win all over the place.
Still incredibly winnable. People just don't People would just
rather complain than actually build something up that could win.
Too bad. I I Frankly, I used the phrase I used the phrase finger
on the scale when I first brought this up in our
Also So, you know,
It's different than rigged. I Those are Those are to me meaningfully
different, meaningly meaningly meaning fully
Putting your finger on the scale versus being rigged.
I don't need to use the term rig- I mean, if that is just a semantic
issue, then we don't have to use that word. Like okay, so like
so like again, to go back to to 2020, like okay, so there's a
sort of minor conspiracy of like of of center-left candidates
dropping out so that Joe Biden gets all of the voters voters
available to that. That strategy simply would not work if the
more progressive candidate, Bernie Sanders, had if if there were
just simply more voters for the progressive candidate than there
were for the center-left candidate. I'd have to see the margins.
How much did Elizabeth Warren staying in
Did it Bernie like a substantial amount or was it just a little
bit? I feel like nobody was voting for Warren, but
I would love to see if I would love to see those numbers. I could
pull them up. I just
I would imagine it's like very little. I think Joe Biden carried
pretty hard once all of the other like spoiler candidates
Yeah, I think I mean there's a few things that happen. As you
are aware, many fewer people vote in primaries than in general
elections and it tends to be more plugged in conventional media
mainstream media watching folks who are tuned into their MSNBC
every day and exactly the people who are getting the overwhelming
message that someone like Bernie Sanders is not Yeah, Conscious
Points is a little bar out. I don't know what's going on here.
Some people are saying it sounds a little bit similar to when
she's like relapsed previously. I don't I don't say that to be
salacious. I say that to be like, maybe it's time to be a little
sensitive.
That's all. On electability, which we know not to be
But this is not the head-to-head polls. This is a problem that
you ought ought to be solvable by generating energy to vote for
more progressive candidates in primaries, right? Like I mean
if like if it's like if it's like Kamala Harris's fault that
she lost in 2024, then isn't it also kind of Bernie Sanders'
fault that he lost in 2020?
What do you mean? How do you mean? Well, by failing to generate
the energy or to to to win when she campaigned in South Carolina
or whatever we think is the condition that Bernie had to have
met to win. The the the problem of how to overcome
the media
and I don't want to overstate I really want to say it was 70
70 million dollars worth of um earned media that came out of
Biden's South Carolina win. Like Bernie fundraised everybody
in the race, but there's only so much you can do about the entire
media infrastructure hailing Joe Biden as the king of the blacks
and the ultimate winner of the election after winning one southern
state that's a red state that actually has no bearing on the
outcome of the general election, right? Oh Biden, the king of
the blacks. Let's go.
This is edited disingenuously.
Highly dishonest framing. I said you seem to think that Democrats
should pivot left to whatever protest voters who by your own
account are not the reason Harris lost. My Democratic Party standards
refers to those voters, not to supporting a genocide. Not supporting
a genocide. As I immediately clarify in this clip, I'm not going
to go on your podcast again if the whole point is to clip these
stupid dunks for Twitter engagement.
Yeah, that unfortunately is the way it is a little bit, man.
>> Dude, I think she jokes about this. Hold on, I think
she jokes about this in the other thread. Hold on.
So Briahna Joy Gray, Jill Stein voter, invites me to on her podcast
Bad Faith. My friends tell me don't do it. Bad Faith is known
for being Bad Faith. I say I'll do it anyway. What? Because one,
losing debates to Bad Faith people is an integral part of my
artistic process, and two,
I'm frustrated that most leftist influencers won't even talk
to me like a human being.
They just treat me like a discursive object they can disingenuously
accuse of genocide for views and clicks. So I appreciate the
opportunity to actually
I do the podcast, lose the debate as usual, fine. Briahna is
smart, like 10 times smarter than the male leftist influencers
get 100 times more the 100 times the recognition she does. Typical.
She's personable, even invites me to hang out later. I think
like a dumbass, maybe this can actually be
But then today she posted a bunch of stupid dunk clips on Twitter.
Notably, this one where she misrepresents my claim that abandoned
Harris protest voters are
far left by Democratic Party standards as a claim that not supporting
genocide is far left. Yeah. Didn't like that. I point this out.
I I point out that this is a blatant misrepresentation and she
blames her producer. I'm generally sorry you feel that way Natalie.
I asked for the three I asked I asked for three clips from every
episode for my producer and generally don't direct which ones
he clips. This week I did specifically ask for an additional
supercut clip. If there's a clip timestamps that you think is
more
representative of our conversation, I'm happy to ask him to clip
it. Your account take responsibility for the things you post
instead of blaming the
I think the clips are good such representative of the conversation
and will be taking them down. But again, if there are additional
clips that you think are that you think provide a more well-rounded
view, I'm happy to clip them. Now, I will say
that with the one she was upset about,
To be honest,
I don't really like I think she's
I don't think the clip is bad. I think the way they title it
like here what they write here before going into it is bad. It
is basically gives people a way to attack ContraPoints without
watching. If you watch, you can see that Briana Joy Gray is being
bad faith in the clip. Right? It's in the clip that she's being
bad faith, that she's intentionally being bad faith here. Like
it's there for anybody who wants to watch, but because the text
doesn't include that, I do think like a lot of people probably
just comment on this without actually watching.
I don't think the clip is disingenuous or edited misleadingly.
I think it's all there in the clip. I just don't think I just
think the
the text is dumb.
The framing is goofy. They are talking about genocide semaphore.
They are. Right? Hold on. Let's see.
I just want to say to me I said you seem to think the Democrats
voters should pivot left to win over protest voters. By your
own account are not the reason Harris lost. Let's watch the video.
So you seem to think that the solution to this is to like for
for if the Democrats pivot to the far left that there's this
like available
>> Well, by Democratic Party
By Democratic Party standards. Well, isn't that quite the admission?
Well, I'm not saying >> quite the admission that we have
a far right Democratic Party if something like ending a genocide
is considered to be far left? Well Yeah, it's all here. It's
all here
in my opinion.
It's like transparently
bad faith. Like she's being like if anybody's and I This the
problem is nobody's actually watching. Nobody actually care.
Nobody will actually watch this and identify what's going on
here, right? I would just say in this alone, in this clip, in
this frame by
or sorry, in this like first 30 seconds, I can tell exactly what
Briahna Joy Gray is trying to go for. Maybe it's cuz I know what
ContraPoints is doing or what she says, right? No. So, what what
she's saying is there are far left people and
like I again, I don't think it's a duck. She's not saying on
that issue, but basically the the problem is this conflation,
right? So, it's a double-ended problem where the only people
who are saying the thing about Palestine, that is like the far
left position, that was the far left position. It was only far
left candidates or far left people who are doing that and they
didn't think it was like electorally responsible at the time
to go and and pivot on Israel, right?
So, it's like not even wrong. It's not that being that being
far left is the only way to be anti-genocide. It's the opposite,
but nobody in the party is willing to support it, so but that
in and of itself is bad for the party cuz they weren't switching
up with the voters, so
I don't know.
Here, let's go back to this.
>> the The Democrats at any point could choose to win.
All they have to do is say, uh we're not going to support a genocide.
Is that too much to ask?
I don't Well, I guess I'm not convinced that the Democrats will
easily win if they simply say we're not going to support a genocide.
>> Why not? I'm looking at the poll now. It was 29%.
Donald Trump won eight perfectly well without making global crisis.
Oh, they talk about They talk about this for a long time. that
Donald Trump can manage this global crisis. And people feeling
really endangered and their health is on the line and they just
need someone normal and sensible back in the White House and
then you get a Joe Biden. And then you see how fragile that coalition
around Joe Biden was 4 years later.
Right? Yes. Well, I but you so you seem to think that the solution
to this is to like for to for for if the Democrats pivot to the
far left that there's this like available for space. Well, by
Didn't
it work?
Well, no cuz Like genocide was in the conversation a lot, but
man, it was not like the topic right before this. They're talking
about COVID and Joe Biden.
That's actually kind of crazy.
in the White House and then you get a Joe Biden. And then you
see how fragile that coalition around Joe Biden was 4 years later.
Right? Yes. Well, What is the quote from Vaush?
I'm not going to tell you how to spend your vote.
I'm I'm not going to tell you how to how to cast your vote. Something
like that. What does he say?
Right, with or without my vote in Washington D.C. and not even
a state, that that is the most effective way for me to actually
politically represent my interests. That's >> My point
here ain't about criticizing your vote. It's that only two people
were going to be president and there My point here ain't about
criticizing your vote. My point here ain't to criticize your
vote. Dude, Vaush
Vaush like Dude, these are Nobody will talk about it cuz he uh
has solicited minors for
Sorry, plans to have engagements with minors when they were minors
when they once they turn into adults. Let's be accurate. Let's
be accurate. Let's be just completely accurate here, okay?
But man, can we acknowledge the gains from Vaush? That like this
is Vaush 3 years ago and this is Vaush now?
Like it's crazy. The difference is crazy. Essentially came because
the people who voted for him wanted the
Totally different looking guy.
He got interested in in fashion and like personal grooming.
Lost a little bit of weight. Very very different guy. Okay, where
are we at? Dude, it it the the context before this doesn't even
matter to be honest with I think everything after this it's like
all
just there. It might even make it might make Brianna Joy Gray
look worse because it's sort of like a pretty strong move away.
But that is kind of what that is kind of what ContraPoints is
sorry, ContraPoints is talking about anyway.
>> No amount of glow from Bosch will mitigate the oral
loss of him and that Floyd leaking. Sorry.
You mean like his the swamp leaks?
>> That's a That is a rough one. That is like a rough one.
Pull it up. I'm not pulling it up. You guys.
I'm not pulling this [__] up. No. No. Tacoma wept,
bro. Tacoma wept, dog. Tacoma wept. Tacoma wept.